whoa Batman I'm sorry that that I just one of my friends
linked me the fucking linked me the tweet and I was like
wait that's actually so good I was just like oh my god I
love that comic to love that meme like donkey this is where
my parents die.
Whoa, Batman!
I'm saying it was so good.
It actually was so fun.
That guy, whoever voice acted for Batman, bro, shout out to
that guy.
That was actually a really good voice acting for Batman.
That was actually really fucking good.
Jeremy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Mine, thank you for the 20 gifted chips.
link don't worry it's uh pinned on my chat it's pinned on
the chat uh link to the to the video i love that fucking
meme anyway it's batman time for those who are actually new
here and never watched a dokey stream before um most likely
90 i forgot majority of the controls i forgot if i'm not
playing a game right away like if i every time i like leave
a game for a while and i come back to it i'm just like what
are the controls what what do i do i think the only thing
can remember is the punching mechanic i think i only where
am i where am i okay this is the all right punch give me a
sec run all right batterang uh three days okay detective
mode god i i still like i really hate the um I do not was
this.
Crouch.
All right.
What is this?
What is RB?
What the fuck is RB?
Okay.
RB is throw.
All right.
We got this.
We're figuring it out.
Very slowly but surely.
Wait.
Oh my gosh.
There's so many plays.
Oh hey.
Ridley.
Nice.
Always want more Ridley trophies.
All right.
RB is grapple.
Okay.
I got this.
I hate the detective mode.
Because the detective mode.
test our detective mode makes it so that's harder to like
see you like the flashes i hate the flashes so much uh
broomstick thank you the super chat thank you thank you glad
to see you so happy dokey here's to a good stream thank you
thank you thank you thank you i'm pretty sure this is not
the right way yeah it's like the little flashbang i really
don't like it oh all right time to beat up do i need to be
stealthy no hey
Wait, how do I dodge?
Oh, it's okay.
They're just dead.
All right.
Wait, wait.
No, I forgot how to do them.
Finish your move.
Okay.
Why?
Okay, there we go.
We're five.
All right, it's coming back to me.
It's like driving a car.
I haven't drove a car in 10 years, but it's just like
driving a car.
There you go.
It's almost just like driving a car.
All right.
I don't think I should touch a car for I don't think so
condition unconscious oh I can like see their heart rate all
right nice at least they're just unconscious uh I mean like
if I can't kill okay not gonna lie if I can't kill I feel
like legally like in the bat rules I should be able to use a
crowbar as long as I don't kill anybody like if I can use
the battering runs, I should be able to use a crowbar.
Because, like, I feel like the batterangs are, like, they're
still metal, right?
So legally, if you think about it, I should be able to also
use a crowbar.
Because I'm already giving them brain damage, right?
So if I'm giving...
Okay, yes, people are like, Batman doesn't kill.
kill them like get making them paralyzed is not killing it's
just very cruel but they're not gonna die like they're not
going to die but I'm just shutting I don't know how to dodge
in the middle of kicking ass super thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you like why do you assume I'm gonna
for the head.
I can I can aim for Jesus Christ.
Think of the Jason Fats.
He lived.
He's still alive.
You can't say that.
Poetry guys.
He's still alive.
Like a serious injury.
But like Batman doesn't care.
He doesn't care if someone seriously injured.
Oh, dokey.
Are you allowed to beat pizza?
Is that, of course I'm allowed to beat pizza.
I fucking eat tomatoes all the time.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Like, all I'm saying is that, look, Batman picks and chooses
a lot with his rules.
That's all I'm saying.
All right, hello.
Oh, shit.
I've got you!
Oh my god!
It's okay.
But all he uses are bad things.
He can't pick up a weapon without bat in front of the name.
I can literally call this a bat bar!
Let's think of the super chat.
Thank you.
I mean, you're still getting air in there.
As long as the gas doesn't...
You really think you can beat the Joker?
I can't even beat the Joker.
I can't even beat the joker leave it cash can you control
the ventilation system in there drag it's a no-go he
disabled remote access i'll find a way wait does he have
like a hook for a hand where's your hand sir wait that's not
even like i guess like arkham asylum doesn't pay very well
because that's not even a prosthetic that's literally a hook
hand like holy shit holy shit shit where is my funding going
I'm fucking Bruce Wayne where is my funding going I funded
like five million dollars to this fucking asylum and all you
can get is a fucking met that's not even good I feel like if
you have a metal literally attached like how does that help
you it's not even a prosthetic you can't even pick anything
you might as well just have a stump hand like Yes, this is a
prison Like I feel like there's no actual use to that
Because you can't pick anything What are you going to do?
Put make holes or something on like pieces of paper Like go
put the TV Oh, use it to press buttons on the TV Oh, yeah,
oh, yeah, sorry All the money went to the TV High on
caffeine Thank you for the magenta soup Thank you, thank you
Wait, you eat tomatoes Wouldn't that be cannibalism?
Someone clearly didn't know my lore.
I had an entire stream dedicated to eating all my tomato
children.
Open the door.
Oh, the door is blocked.
Okay, what do we do?
Alright, clearly...
We don't do anything here.
Alright, yeah, the weak should eat the strong.
Exactly.
Now you're speaking my language.
It's called survival of the fittest.
Bruce Wayne has money.
You're Batman.
Alright, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright, check the map.
No!
I'm going to figure this out by pure instinct.
This is called the gamer instinct.
Can I just leave that guy to die?
Does he actually matter?
I'm pretty sure he doesn't matter.
Okay, let's see.
Where do I go?
I go?
I clearly can't do anything here.
Did I jump?
I'm gonna jump.
Okay, I should not have jumped.
Use detective mode!
No!
Okay, I should use detective mode.
Uh... Oh.
You used to remove pure... Okay, but how do I get there?
Can I just...
Can I just do this?
Okay, no.
But what do I do?
Conditioned, terrified.
Can I just kill him?
There you go.
I mean, he's unconscious, so he's still okay.
I can't let that man be in the room of toxic as quickly as
possible.
I can't let this man die.
Well, that's unfortunate then.
He's okay.
I mean, look, see, he still has a heart rate.
Like, what's gonna happen to him?
I mean, he's still okay.
That was a big fall.
Look, he's okay.
Look at him.
Look, we can, look, see?
It's not even red.
It's like yellow.
All right.
We gotta figure this out.
Okay.
What the fuck do I?
Let's see.
Like, see, he's unconscious.
Guys, he's not dead.
He's just unconscious.
Can't fucking grapple anywhere.
Where is it?
Where do I go?
I feel like this is not where I should be going.
He's just...
Sorry, I mean, I'm just gonna leave him.
I feel like we don't have to do anything with this guy.
Glide?
glide where i feel like i can't even okay let's try we okay
don't worry i'm okay i'm okay let's try this again i can i
got this i can't wait wait wait i got this i have so much hp
i have so much how do i glide again There you go.
God damn it.
Okay.
Okay, I got this.
Wee.
I'll eventually make it.
It's okay.
I'm alive.
Oh.
Someone held bad, baby.
I was sorry.
I didn't realize there was a limit to how many times I could
do.
No, I didn't do this again!
God damn it, okay.
I didn't realize it's okay.
I wanted to beat him up again anyway.
All right, it's all right.
It's fine.
All right, but he's laughing.
He's clearly having a good time.
All right, we'll be fine.
Let's see.
All right, if If he's laughing, why are you dead?
And Takeda, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yo, golden trophy bird.
Hope you're doing well.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm doing great.
I'm good to play Batman.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
We can do this again.
Alright.
Don't worry.
You'll be okay.
Yay.
See, he's fine.
See, I got XP.
If it's not fine, Why did I get XP?
Just think of that.
If it was not fine, why did it give me experience points?
Oh my god, it's right here.
Guys, who the fuck said glide?
Who the fuck said glide?
Who said glide?
It was literally right there.
Oh, whoops.
Whoops, I know!
I don't think I fit it.
Now, glide.
Wait.
Wait, is that not- did I not fix the gas?
Where else would there be gas?
I thought I fixed it.
You used to remove- Wait, where did I not fix it?
Look, it's- it's going on.
lessened?
Oh!
Okay.
Fly to a part above the ass.
Wee!
Nice.
I did it.
Alright, where do I have to go?
See, it's okay.
Look, he's still unconscious.
Nice.
I'm doing it.
Okay.
There's...
Yeah, there it is.
Oh.
whoop there we go i'm doing it of course i am i'm batman all
right is that everything sam thank you the super chat thank
you thank you hey doki i'm the one who invented the wallow
swallowing at a time i was wondering if you could give a
short motivational speech rambay who is down in the dumps
love you platonically always always always swallowing with
all of these
Alex, thank you for the gifted ship.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright.
Is that everything?
What else is there?
Oh, hey.
Boop.
Wait, did I got the XP I did?
Nice.
What do I glide?
What else?
Is this still laughing gas?
No, it's not.
Boop.
What do you mean?
I literally solved this myself.
You guys said glide.
You guys gave me instructions out of order, and I figured it
out myself.
Nice.
Look at that.
Aaron Cash.
Are you relevant?
One of the most senior and respected guards at Arkham.
Cash is only afraid of one inmate.
Killer Croc was severely wounded.
Cash once during a riot.
Cash remains determined.
to keep the asylum ailments under control and to conquer his
fears of Croc.
Not the Joker?
I mean, I guess like, because like the killer Croc ate his
hand.
I still think that is like the worst prosthetic you can ever
get because you can't do anything with that.
Like, it's literally just two hooks.
What can you grab?
I guess like your shirt.
What if you need it like, like it's so useless.
Like, what do you grab?
What?
Oh shit, he's a real person in 2003.
Hello, I saved your life.
You're welcome, guys.
So what's going on?
My radio went dead soon after you brought Joker in.
We lock him up, he gets out, and more people die.
If I just had one minute alone at that hour.
I'm back scratcher.
Who's interviews this?
Patient's name is Edward Napop.
Why do I have to use the bathroom?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
To
be fair, a lot of villains have, like, terrible childhoods.
That's why they hate the world.
Very well.
I was determined to prove him wrong.
So I entered a contest.
A prize to the kid who could figure out an almost
impossible...
He was convinced I had cheated.
He kept yelling, you must have cheated.
Admit it, you moron, you cheated.
I swore I did.
Whoa.
Where's the mom?
I'm sorry to hear that.
Wait, he did cheat?
You're a fucking cheater?
Oh my god.
I can't believe it, Riddler.
What about integrity?
Astro, thank you for the gifted ship.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, where do I go?
Where am I supposed to go?
I already got a doc.
Oh, we have to get multiple doctors.
I forgot.
It's not just one doctor.
Okay, but is there, like, anything important here?
At all?
I feel like there was, like, a vent above here, right?
Wait, oh, I can open doors.
Hello.
Oh, hey, he's a guy.
See, he's alive.
See?
Look at that.
Batman never kills.
I told you I can't kill.
There's a riddle in there.
There is.
wait where is it is it in here because i can't open that yet
i think it has to be in there it's fine we don't need it yet
i told you just like you know permanent damage to the
physical body but that's okay that's what doc that's why
we're saving the doctors that's why oh it's in the mirror oh
shit okay newspaper articles in room with man Shit, what was
the, what was this firefly too hot?
All right, let's see.
All right, don't worry.
Okay, this is important, sir.
Okay, wait.
There you go.
Subject too small?
What else am I supposed to look at?
What?
How is it too small?
Is it because I'm looking at it too hard?
Oh, zoom in.
Okay.
all right okay clearly not how much more how do i zoom oh
okay there you go all right here you go i did it firefly
escapes gotham on high alert oh my god recently free youtube
shorts thank you um for destroying the comics industry
i learned about there's like this villain in batman called
the calendar man and like before they reconned him to be
like a super serious villain he would like kill villains on
holidays which i don't know it feels like okay i in my
opinion if the villain all he does is kill people wait kill
people on holidays then like you know who did it like
oh shit what like oh my god somebody died on christmas he
was murdered who could it be well the only person that kills
people during the holidays is this one particular villain so
it has to be calendar man it just feels very i don't know
like if you're gonna kill somebody i feel like you should it
should be more random than a holiday nice thank you for the
free stuff I actually thought it was going to be like...
Nice.
Yay!
That's the point.
Some villains like that, but it's stupid!
Like, they don't want to get caught, so why would you do the
one thing that gets you caught?
Okay, we gotta go for this one.
Why is it yellow?
Okay.
He did more than kill people.
He did a ton of holiday-themed crime.
Then you know who did it.
Monster, thank you for this super chat.
Thank you.
It doesn't matter.
It's still on a holiday.
They want to get caught?
The rehabilitation doesn't work, Batman.
He's encouraging.
Oh, is this saw?
Don't speak.
You're safe now.
But it's a trap.
I know.
Just not for me.
It's true.
You really are the world's greatest detective.
That's not even a puzzle.
It's a trap.
Oh yeah, really?
Who would have thought this was a trap all along?
Oh my god!
He's alone in there by himself!
What could happen?
Wow, okay, hey man.
I'm trying to do a combo move right now.
Excuse me.
Why are you disturbing my combo?
Oh shit, go come on let me beat him up.
Let me give your friend brain damage.
Nice Come on, let me punch you in the day.
Come on.
You know you want to Okay, nice easy excuses Yay I'm just
softening you up.
Think of this as a preview to the main event.
You'll see.
What's up here?
I'll free you later.
Sorry, this is important.
Counter button.
What do you mean?
I counted so much.
Okay, Arkham Night Shift.
Dr. T.
Elliott.
Dr. P. Young.
Dr. Wait.
Time.
Week one, week two.
Wait, there's only one doctor per Night Shift?
Killer Croc Transfer Week 2 nurses That is not a lot of
nurses For like an asylum Because asylum is filled with like
Crazy people because that's what an asylum Is for I feel
like nine nurses That is That is definitely understaffed
That is definitely I'd have solved All the puzzles by now
Yeah this feels incredibly understaffed hush oh that's the
crazy guard right dr ellie and bruce ring were childhood
friends and unknown to bruce dark reflection of each other
childhood sociopath ellie tried to kill his parents so he
can tear at their fortune his plan oh no it wasn't the guard
okay this is a different person i know there was a batman
movie about this i just realized how many like i there was
like did you know they made a movie about soviet soviet
superman and batman and i was like what the there are so
many different types of dc movies yeah called the red it's
like what if superman didn't land in america and landed in
fucking russia and i was like holy fuck and then like
russian batman kills everybody like i was just like holy
shit russian batman does not give a fuck he murders everyone
um uh anyway cool arrow thank you super chat thank you thank
you it's the freaking bat yeah yeah russian russian batman
kills everyone and then lex luther becomes fucking president
of the united states of america okay i'll childhood
sociopath when his plans failed partly due to the surgical
skills of Thomas Wayne versus father Elliot blamed Bruce an
incredibly skilled surgeon as an adult Elliot planned an
elaborate revenge on on scheme on Batman he disguised
himself as the villain Hush his face covered in banishes but
is when the end defeated and amassed by the dark night Hush
still plots revenge against Batman generating complicated
schemes with surgical position which Wait, so he's just
Batman with too much money.
So he's literally just Bruce Wayne with a lot of fucking
money.
That's cool.
But instead he's evil.
But if he's like, okay, all I'm saying is that, like, okay,
Batman, he runs a company that develops weapons.
Tommy Elliot is just a surgeon.
where is he how is he i don't know how you can compare to
like anything else he's literally just a surgeon like how is
he how is he getting his weapon he has guns yes but clearly
they're not great weapons he's literally just a surgeon
batman at least has a fucking like was it fortune 500
company that specifically develops weapons and armor.
Great physical strength augmented by a hatred of Bruce
Wayne.
World class search and capable of extraordinarily medical
breakthroughs.
Master of Disguise.
But how?
How is he a Master of Disguise?
He's just, he just has, it's still gonna be the same body.
I'm so many questions about this one character he's just so
hateful he changes his face but he still has the same body
type i'm sorry i tried to tell you i couldn't speak relax
you're safe now i can handle these low life thugs whoa don't
you need to be like have anesthesia it's for for like any
type of surge holy shit there's no way okay all right i know
like we keep we keep interrupting this gameplay with like
fun facts but like eventually by the time if you keep
fucking giving yourself plastic surgery there's like nothing
left to fix
because like at that are you okay also are you okay dr
adrian chen like you are mentally not okay um but like the
more plastic surgery you get the more fucked up your face is
gonna get um anyway um not so Deadpool American Batman's
parents were killed killed uh Soviet Batman had oh my god
are you okay I think I will be okay thank you for stopping
them god they're syringes syringes are you okay how much how
many like meds did they put in you they tortured me set me
as i don't think he's gonna be okay can i go through here i
don't think i can how do i deactivate this
all right good night thank you for this super chat thank you
thank you type it's just a large white man do you have any
idea how many of those are in the dc universe
okay wait you got me there that is true you got me there you
want to get a present yay Yay!
Yay!
More XP.
Let's go.
All right, let's see.
Where's the last one?
The last one is all the way over here.
Nice.
All right, I figured it out.
It's this way.
Presence!
There's a lot of met.
Oh, that's a lot of shotgun bullets.
Oh, where do I go?
Okay, this way.
Sometimes the map is, like, really difficult to navigate.
But that is only half the story.
I swear, everybody in the DC universe is, like, jacked as
fuck.
Like, everyone has, like, a 20-year membership in...
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
Really, Joker?
Is this the best one, best people you can send?
Woo!
There you go.
Nice.
I love just pressing a I mean X I had to look down because I
had to look down my controller there it's all just there
there is a problem in there in the Gotham water supply whoa
oh shit that's a lot of people wait out i am quite aware
that this job i'm gonna tag this wall
no how do i attack the wall how do i how do i do it oh there
it is
yeah i did it wait she's dead someone tell joker
Wait, there was an innocent person over there?
Whoops, sorry I didn't I didn't realize I didn't realize
there was an innocent person there Whoops, I did it Whoops
Alright, don't worry.
Okay, I didn't realize...
Okay, look.
I didn't realize that, you know, there were important people
here.
How the fuck was I supposed to know?
Oh, hey, they're really losing.
I thought like they were just having a nice conversation,
like, together.
How is there more than one wall?
Don't worry.
It's non-legal.
Bad.
Okay.
I'm not killing civilians.
They're the ones killing civilians.
I'm just here to have a good time.
What the fuck?
Oh, okay.
There's the other wall.
Alright.
I'm gonna tag this wall, I guess.
I fucked up.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, let me finish tagging!
I pressed the wrong one!
No,
I pressed...
I'm sorry, I can't read!
I pressed RB!
I was like, hold RT, oh, hold RB!
Hold, hold RB!
All right, okay, I figured it out.
Guys, this time, this time it's different.
This time it's different.
All right.
RT.
There we go.
Guys, I don't use controller very often.
Guys, is it noticeable that I don't use controller?
And Dr. Young!
First try.
Let's go.
Dr. Young!
First try.
You definitely did not die two times before I saved you.
Unfortunately, yes.
But not for long.
I'm very confident in my job.
The warden was very specific he wanted Joker cured.
Bad publicity will affect his campaign for mayor.
oh do not worry penny young you were the last one i say
don't worry doctor medical staff are safe yeah all of them
are safe now they're all you were you were the last one
all right let's see i want to make sure i didn't miss
anything here let's see is there anything is there anything
i'm missing jp thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you i didn't fuck up guys i didn't fuck up i made a slight
miscalculation and no lies were injured in the process okay
as the greatest detective in the world it was just a little
oopsie that can be It's fixable.
Where's the last present?
I'm so calm.
Wow!
Alright, nice.
See, I told you.
I told you I'm calm.
Nice.
Oh, wait, I should put back the battery.
I have a second.
Nice.
Boop.
I fucking popped out, like, Marilyn Monroe there.
Don't keep them messed up.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right, where do I go?
Uh, oh, I gotta go back.
I was so calm.
What do you mean?
the shit out of him there's a children's area there's
fucking super villains and we put a children's area in the
asylum what the fuck is wrong with Gotham this
what evil kids bro why is there a children's area did you
find them are they Yes, they're safe now Batman We've got
another problem I need to get back to the mansion All my
research notes are there There's a mansion?
It's not safe, Doctor.
The island's a war zone You won't stand a chance It's my
life's work And so I thank you for the super chat, thank you
I think she's beginning to figure out the problem Where I
come asylum There's like, this is not even Like a problem,
this is like this is a mistake get her notes and then find
somewhere safe to hold up everyone else go to the
observation room barricade yourselves in all right don't
worry we got oh shit they have guns okay that's not good
okay they have guns now all right let's see oh fuck they
have shotguns wait a minute oh wait I want to grab these.
Okay.
Maybe if I do that and I grapple here and then...
Alright, wait, where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
Where are they going?
Okay, they're going here.
Okay.
Let me head to the gargoyle and then...
Come over here.
Come on.
Come on!
How the fuck am I supposed to get you over here?
No, no Batman.
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Use detective mode.
Why do I need to use detective mode?
I need them to, like, come over to me.
Wait, the floor is breakable?
The floor is breakable?
No, it's not.
Oh, yeah, it is.
Oh, shit, you're right.
Okay, the structural weakness critter.
Why is there structural weakness?
Did no one fucking do anything to this?
All I'm saying is, why the fuck is there structural weakness
in it?
Okay, all right.
This whole entire area is fucked, man.
Can I just land there and...
okay wait and then you tagging it real fast you know why
every time I learned more about how poorly this place is
built I'm still surprised and I don't know why I should stop
being surprised about how terrible this place is hello hello
over here come on i have the the wall over here come on get
over here come on
yeah yeah i did don't look up no no
Yeah, go over there.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Go ahead.
Wait, where are they?
Where are they going?
You know, I could might as well just kill this guy.
You know, fuck it.
Oh, shit, no!
Oh, wait, nice.
He's unconscious.
Okay, I'll take that.
Okay.
I'll take that, actually.
Okay, nice.
Alright.
Okay, I'm just making it much more complicated than it
should be.
Wait, wait, wait.
Yes!
No!
Okay, I fucked up.
I thought he...
I thought he was gonna get closer to me.
Yes.
Yes!
Nice!
Alright.
I failed successfully.
And then Glide Kick.
Yay!
Easy.
But, uh, failed successfully.
I told you guys I can do this.
Alright, where am I supposed to go now?
Can I actually upgrade my stuff?
No, I don't have enough.
But, Dokey, Batman does have guns too incredibly well-toned
guns thank you for the super chat thank you thank you uh
poultry guys all right backseat time what do i upgrade
what's important what is important guys extreme violence all
right what what is important guys hp throw health okay
health all right here nice martha all right nice all right
hp time okay where do i go i still have to go here return to
the doctors and pick up gordon's uh tobacco trail okay all
right i gotta figure this out is it like here no okay wrong
way wrong way i'll forever be lost in this hell hole oh my
god okay this way Up I go.
Cool man, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you.
Oh, think about it.
Precariously over a deadly drop.
What say I just blow the- Do it!
Do it, no boss?
I got a sack of puppies.
Joker would never do it because like, he gets his kicks
going by, by having Batman as like an arch enemy.
Got a few more surprises in store for you.
Prepare to face your face.
His greatest fear is like losing Batman and then becoming an
office worker.
Wait, Scarecrow?
Where the fuck is Scarecrow?
What's wrong?
Are you gonna take your hat off to Harley Bats?
Wait, is it gonna become a horror story?
Is it gonna come out last?
What is Batman scared of?
Riddle's!
I'm scared of not getting that riddle trophy.
Joker, no matter what, there is one fangirl out there that
would love to see you in a thong.
i.e.
Harley.
Taxes, my number one fear.
Okay, let's see.
Oh, wait, what?
developed by when these control points are considered hack
proof.
That is such a fucking lie.
Why does it keep telling me it's hack proof?
It is not hack proof.
Even Joker can fucking hack into this.
Okay, let's put this on.
Hanging this.
Nice.
Okay.
What every billionaire sphere taxes.
Yeah, I feel like Batman has multiple offshore accounts.
Gordon?
Gordon!
Watch it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, yeah.
It is canon.
His biggest fear is the IRS.
I forgot about that.
Oh.
Alright, let's go.
Let me in.
Gordon?
Gordon, you okay?
Okay.
Gordon, look at me.
You gotta blink or your eyes or you're gonna dry out.
I'm sorry, Jim.
Wait, is he dead?
What?
They just killed off Jim Gordon?
Wait, no.
I have to be having a nightmare right now.
There's no fucking way Jim Gordon just dies like that.
There is no way.
This has to be a nightmare.
Batman, wake up!
Hunt down Commissioner.
There's no fucking way.
There's no way.
There's no way they...
They just kill him like that!
I must be dreaming.
I must be having a nightmare from the scarecrow.
Yeah, this is definitely a nightmare.
Okay, look.
Look, this place sucks, but it doesn't suck that much.
The morgue.
Oh, shit.
People are going to come alive, aren't they?
I don't like this.
I am not a fan of this.
I am not a fan.
When did this become out last?
Wait,
this is the morgue.
Where are the dead?
dead bodies.
Hello?
How do I get out?
How do I...
I don't know how!
Do I
just...
I'm sinking!
You can't keep sinking out of here!
Don't tell me how!
The voices...
They're getting loud!
there okay fine fine fine oh shit oh hey oh he did he did
want me to get out of here okay wait are you telling me i
should have got out of there no way dad this is where my
parents died no way
mom turns out it was that easy I should have got out of
there Jesus Christ trauma is this gonna be me Bruce oh
scarecrow the top voices told me whoa whoa I actually got
goosebumps from that that's so fucking cool oh I don't have
detective mode No, no, he took away the one thing I have.
I'm the world's greatest detective, but I can't get into
detective mode.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The voice has told you to get.
I like how they're like, get out of there.
I was like, what do I do, chat?
I don't understand.
What?
Oh shit giant scarecrow.
Put a shirt on.
Ow.
Wait what do I do?
I just run?
I'm just gonna run.
Oh okay.
Where's that?
Okay.
Okay I gotta go up I'm just gonna wait Alright You're in my
realm now Everything is as real as I Choose it to be Is this
scam me?
Nice, okay, that does it Alright Where do I go?
Where do I go?
Do I?
What?
Huh?
What happened?
Wait, is this the...
This has to be the...
Just punch the wascare crow okay oh my god please tag faster
please tag faster oh shit okay how the fuck was i supposed
to know he was gonna he was gonna go faster all right
all right nice okay let's go run just got run just got one
just got one all right and then crouch all right if he
really wanted to kill me you could just punch the wall it's
not that hard
Welcome to my world, Batman.
Oh, crotch, crotch, crotch, crotch, crotch.
All right, nice.
All right.
Okay, we gotta bring up...
I wish he could tag things faster, but he still needs to
draw the bat signal on everything.
All right, please, please, please, Batman.
Please!
It's not that cool!
Okay.
Nice.
Not here.
Oh, where could I be?
Whoa, I wonder where I could be right about now.
Whoa.
Nice.
Okay.
There's no way he's going to look past this wall, right?
There's no fucking way.
Okay, I don't know his pattern right now, so I'm, like,
scared.
I'm actually scared.
okay nice I swear if he like fucking looks back as like a
the gotcha moment
what was that my biggest fear light
that's fucking right get flashbanged what silent killer of
the oceans can be found in a tiny jar what it can wait what
all right character bio is he is that him the scarecrow
taunted and bullied as a youth jonathan crane vowed to
overcome his fear through the study of psychology and
biochemistry kicked out of his university for experimenting
on human subjects crane then adopted the identity of the
scarecrow and armed himself with specialized fear-inducing
gas that makes the person's deepest phobias become
frighteningly real his ongoing criminal reign of terror
makes him one of batman's most psychologically dangerous
bows stupid crane you have to go through animals and then
experiment on humans because apparently that's how ethical
apparently that's more ethical you can experiment on humans
all you want you just gotta follow the process like all
right let's see professional what the fuck Occupation.
Professional criminal.
That's his job.
Alright.
He just needs to follow the process.
And then he can experiment on as many humans as he wants.
Welcome to science.
Had a little run-in with scarecrow.
Slowed me down.
I'll get back to you in a bit.
The jar.
Oh, there's the jar.
There it is.
What is that?
Is that finger?
Oh, shit.
No, not my explosive jail.
Subject too small.
Do I have to fucking scan this?
Okay.
All right.
What the fuck is that?
That one could have been solved by a monkey.
But good job, nevertheless.
What is that?
Oops, sorry.
The great white shark.
A crooked financer who stole millions of dollars.
Warren Wright thought he'd scored a legal victory when his
insanity P. Lee went through.
But when he got...
I actually don't know this criminal.
But when he got to Arkham Asylum, he realized his mistake
driven insane by the other mistakes he was also disfigured
by an encounter with mr freeze that left him without hair oh
my god it's Voldemort a nose ears or lips calling himself
the great white shark he filled his teeth into he filed his
teeth into fangs to more perfectly resemble his new namesake
putting the financial skills to use he has become a major
player in Gotham's underground crime scene running a number
of rackets from Oh, so he's like the the accountant for like
criminals
He's like the main accountant Warren white The underrated
villain.
I mean I mean he's an accountant so Like wow, I'm so scared
when she uses for a variety of criminal purposes It's kind
of massage that makes him resemble a shark thief sharpened
like i'm just saying he's he's just he's an accountant he's
not like an actual villain he's just there to help the
villains do their taxes because like i assume the villains
can't have like regular accountants right so like obviously
it makes sense that like they have to get a villain
accountant also i'm gonna use the bathroom i'll be right
back i'm
back guys okay the best part about like playing on
controller is that i can actually i can actually just i'm
like lounging on my chair i'm playing this game next thing
thank you the super chat thank you thank you are you eyes
green or gray um is green if it's sometimes gray it's
because i accidentally have the green screen on it that's
the only reason why sometimes it's gray all right hey oh hey
what's the why is your arrow signs but that's stupid i need
is batman that directly challenged that the game was like it
wasn't gordon i knew it cream's gas must have knew it
there's no way they would just killed gordon that fast
having trouble figuring out what's real and what's just a
figment of your twisted little mind saying here just roam
with the bats It gets easier once you get in.
It really does.
But already...
Whoa!
Shit!
Don't worry.
Oh, I can't.
Wait, can I dodge that?
No, I can't.
If I just keep...
If I just keep punching...
If I just keep punching!
He'll die eventually!
Okay.
Oh, shit.
No.
No, come on!
Let me fucking finish him!
all right nice oh my god okay i did not need a dick punch
that guy all right nice how come i can't dodge nice oh wait
it won't let me like it won't let me punch him when like
he's upright
i don't know this puzzle you're not the really all right
okay he wants me to go this way but I don't go that way.
What if I go this way?
Okay, actually, I don't know where this way goes.
Okay, let's just go back.
Like, okay, maybe I should go this way.
I didn't really...
Okay, but like, isn't Gordon...
I feel like Gordon's pretty fucking shit at his job.
Not gonna lie.
His whole thing was, like, to defeat corruption.
But, like...
Does it look like it's going well?
crime doesn't come cheap they go if they got to pay their
taxes rob thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
he's trying his best this is bear the bane of his life look
harley's under strict instructions to kill the old man
so here's the deal if you could find a way to get to harley
without anyone realizing i'll give you your next present
fail and the old
Bro, what the fuck?
Bro, why do you keep fucking giving Harley...
Harley away?
I said, no!
It's a stealth mission!
Okay.
Alright, it's time to stealth.
Alright, not gonna lie, the fact that he keeps giving away
Harley, it's not great.
At least top 10%.
All right, let's open this.
Yeah, this is really giving me some heavy NTR vibes, man.
Jokey, I'm not, I don't really want to know what's going on
in your bedroom life right about now.
But like, as Batman,
Batman has enough lady problems at the moment.
So like, I really don't care.
once the old man kept safe for batman anyone gets near him
thank you thank you joker more like the cucker oh my god oh
yes goo number 200 is gonna kill me all right here i go
harley please is this really what you want harley
Can I kill him?
Or do I just walk past?
Do I just walk past him?
There's no way he noticed.
There's no way.
There's no...
Oops.
You know what?
Fuck it.
There's no way, right?
There's no way.
Nice, alright.
It's okay.
If I don't see what they actually look like, I can't
humanize him.
You guys fucked up?
That's what, like, that's like an actual, like, strategy.
Oh, hey, really?
Nice.
As long as you don't humanize them and you don't see what
they look like, it's okay.
Get over here.
So, like, I'm not actually killing anybody.
All right.
Can you see me through the...
Can you see me through this?
It's great.
There's just skeletons.
Skeletons aren't real.
All right.
Is that him?
Skeletons aren't real.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Come on, turn around.
Turn around.
Okay, nice.
Well.
I like how I, like, jab him in the fucking back.
All right, we gotta get the last guy.
Okay, how the fuck do I get the last one?
Guess what's inside you right now?
Blood!
What else would be inside me?
Okay, you can't see me from there.
Wait, who's that over there?
A blue skill.
Okay, I'm just gonna...
Okay, it would really suck if you just turned around.
There we go.
What's...
Yeah, tomato!
See?
Okay.
There's a no right here.
Holy fuck.
Okay.
Okay, okay, that would have been...
That would have been awkward.
Okay, how do I do this?
Alright, a little oopsie there, but it's okay, they can't
hear.
Oh, I get past this.
Okay.
You can't hear this.
Okay, pick up.
Can I just drop down?
What if I just drop down?
Okay, I'm like worried if I drop down.
Do I drop?
Wait, is that?
That's glass, right?
Is that glass?
I can't tell if that's glass.
Oh, shit, it is.
Okay.
Can I?
No, I can't.
Oh, wait, can I?
Now I can be broken with enough force.
Okay.
Tagging it?
Okay, I feel like I might die if I do this.
Okay, I'll stand over.
Nice.
You took longer than I thought.
He's out of control.
He's trying to prove something.
I'm not sure I can stop him this time.
You'll do it.
Batman, listen.
We're not alone.
Gordon, please just kill him, Gordon.
Batman will keep thinking rehabilitation will work.
Gordon, just kill him.
Oh, am I getting to you?
Am I?
God.
You're going to love this next bit.
It wants Dr. Young's login.
Never mind that.
Get behind me now.
Bane.
oh shit wait that's Bane I thought he broke
up what is Joker doing
huh wait was one of the doctors was that doctor I saved evil
oh fuck no
please don't break my back oh yeah like that's gonna do
anything bad man no my back
oh shit oh fuck okay oh shit okay how do i do this oh i
forgot to dodge how do i dodge how do you dodge oh shit oh
okay guys guys how the fuck do you dodge again i Don't worry
about my fear.
Okay.
Why?
Can I just punch you?
Oh, my God.
Bro.
Babe, please.
Please.
Oh, like, okay.
I figured it out.
I figured.
Oh, God.
Okay.
What if I just throw back?
it runs at you okay what did i do i wasn't the doctor what
the did i do okay okay all right come over here there's a
wall there was a wall okay what the did i do
oh shit okay that was my bad how could you not running into
a wall to stun bin while he is charging oh okay okay i have
to stun him while he's charging i thought to make him run
into a wall
okay oh all right there you go come on charge me that's
right that's fucking right I'm sorry I'm so sorry I didn't
mean that okay that's fucking right yeah that's fucking
right get a concussion it's the legal way where you can't
die can't see that's right open your eyes I don't want to
get near the last time I got near him You fucking punched me
back.
Wait, he couldn't heal himself?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay.
Oh, shit.
Oh, I do have to get near him.
Nice.
Yoink.
All right, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
Guys, I'm learning.
Wait, what?
That's not fair.
This is a 1v1.
Wait a minute.
Wait a minute Wait a minute.
What happened to the 1v1?
Oh, I am so fucked Please I can't get away from that Please
where's myself here?
Please please friendly fire friendly fire.
Yes, there is okay okay there's friendly fire that's all
that matters i'm so happy there's friendly fire holy fuck
all right we're fine we're fine we're fine hey i'm learning
that's fucking ray they're dead i'm like one hit i'm so
fucked Oh my god, please, please hit each other.
Please.
Please hit each other.
Oh, please.
Yes.
I'm just.
I'm just hope.
Yes.
Nice.
Okay.
I don't have to worry about them.
I just need them to hit each other.
That's fucking right what you're gonna do, huh?
If I keep running.
There you go.
Nice.
Yes!
One HP!
And a dream!
It's like bowling.
It really is actually.
It actually is like bowling.
I learned.
I didn't have to do anything.
Thank fucking god there's friendly fire.
Oh, the Batmobile!
I'm fine, Jim.
Where's Quinn?
have gotten loose while bane was throwing you around we need
to get you off the island i'm not a rookie i can handle
myself oh what the how do you still have all those juices no
no not my back i will not my back no bane this time i break
you Oh!
My car!
Bro, that was like $50 million.
Bruce.
We could have we could have solved the homeless problem in
Gotham City with that money.
Not the Papal view.
Gotham will panic.
You're needed there.
tax right off
it has to be the the doctor that went back to the mansion
and get the papers frosty and kai thank you for the joining
the tomato farm thank you go through the city's computers
pull up all you can find on dr young all right in prison
right from birth to serve his dead father's sentence bain
was raised inside the horrific ruins of a Santa Prisca
prison.
His only friend in the hellhole was a teddy bear named
Osito.
Finding solace in smuggled books and meditation, he
developed incredible powers of concentration.
When he was subjected to military experience using a steroid
code named Venom, his iron forge will helped him survive
when other test subjects had died, and he managed to escape.
Determined to prove his worth, he sought out Batman and
broke the Dark Knight's spine.
Like, if he knew that worked, why doesn't he just always try
to break his spine?
Think about it.
Okay, but if you think about it, like, you know, like, it
put him out of commission for a very long time.
So, like, it clearly worked.
So, like, why doesn't he just keep breaking his spine until
he can't walk?
Rage, thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Just lurking.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for your first Akasupa.
slash super chat.
Thank you.
Awesome, Corrine.
Welcome.
Thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
Uh, alright.
But Batman recovered and managed to best Bane.
But like he never tries to break his spine again.
Cutting off the precious venom supply and transforms Bane
into a superhuman.
He just gave up after the first time went on venom green.
5 foot 6.
He's 5 foot 6 without venom?
Bro!
Master strategist, intense focus, abnormally strong
reactions, determined to best Batman and all the other who's
challenged him.
I'll go through anything you find once I get to the cave.
There's a bad cave here?
It's best to plan ahead for situations like this.
How'd you manage to keep this a secret?
Batman, there's nine nurses and you built a bad cave!
Did you think Dr. Young's been experimenting animal?
Yes, I'm worried.
Bane seemed even more powerful than usual.
Joker wants the venom, and that can only be trouble.
I'm heading to Dead Man's Point in Arkham North.
I'll contact you once I'm in a while.
Bane is a short game.
CJ, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy shit, X, thank you for the 50 gifted ships.
Thank you so much.
Oh my god, that's a lot.
Batman, you could have given them free healthcare.
That is so true!
I was like, there's like so many things wrong with Batman's
logic.
This, the asylum, this entire island is run by nine nurses.
Plus like five doctors or some shit.
And then he built a fucking bat cave.
He was like, what can we do to fix the mental health issues
in Gotham City?
Let me build another bat cave.
like beat up the issue.
Like, I don't understand his logic.
More, yeah, there's more security than there are nurses.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
Okay, you know what?
Fuck, I can... I need XP anyway.
Like, it's always nice to have XP.
Oh.
Critical strike.
Nice.
Oh, my God.
Look at how strong I am now.
Ow.
Please, I'm pressing Y!
If I keep pressing X, they'll die eventually.
Okay, come on.
Get over here.
If you solve all the problems, there will be no need for
Batman.
That is actually so fucking dark.
Like, this is just a fucking...
ego trip for batman you know like he's just like he's he
does all of this just to feel good about himself like oh wow
not having being a billionaire is just not good enough he
needs more
my parents died
is that a tear i see too painful we'll come back to it later
then how about baby boy then oh that you were shocked to see
not really this is like an asylum feel criminalist i was
hoping he'd fold you up like a piece of paper and let me
stamp you crazy but even i don't get everything i want so
what was he doing here Questions, questions!
Well, I'm assuming because you wanted to research the venom,
right?
If you're researching the venom, then...
Then, like, that's why you brought him here?
Because of the doctor?
Alright, here we go.
It's how you find his work.
What the fuck is this?
Turn around.
Don't walk too late.
Alright, let's go.
Where am I?
I'm still lost.
Oh, shit.
It's okay.
More XP.
Hello!
I gotta beat you up for XP.
Let's go.
Grab the back crowbar!
Nice.
Wait, do I actually get XP?
I can't tell.
Yes, I do.
Nice.
Easy.
the bat crowbar because someone was like no Batman can't use
regular items he only used items with the word bat in it
what's stopping him from fucking dubbing this the crowbar
and bat crow get the bat gun
the door is locked alright what the fuck I guess I got to go
all the way backwards oh I have to go oh my gosh I have to
go like the other way way around like okay you know how he's
like he can't kill right i can i can get a bad gun and i
just shoot i just shoot the legs like shoot the foot like
that's all i don't kill like i rather i feel like giving
like like a minor like foot injury is like better than brain
damage
I once saved an unfortunate inmate From leaping off into the
rocks below I found a cave entrance Okay, sorry Batman, this
is more important.
Upgrades.
Alright guys, what do I upgrade next Guys?
What's next?
Sorry, sorry for the lore Interruption.
What should I get next?
Remote combo throw?
Is the throw actually better?
Okay, I'm going to get the combo through.
No one said maybe armor because you almost I almost died but
like I didn't.
Yes, I almost but I did it.
Twin batter as because they're cool.
Okay, we're not taking the advice from the guy that just
once said to look cool.
We are not taking advice from that okay upgrade the twin
okay uh i'm gonna get the combo there then over the years
have moved a number of supplies here it's a regular home
away from home all right let's see this this way open what
how the do i get out open i don't remember oh it's this way
twiddled and twiddled um saw it can you see it.
Alright, you guys have to help me with those riddles.
I'm not smart enough for this.
Alright, up I go.
Okay, not up, clearly.
Oh, wait, really?
Nice.
He can use a pro bar Jason where he suffered from PTSD.
He doesn't do a fuck about Jason.
Oh, shit.
That's a lot of them.
That's okay.
Free XP.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
God damn it!
I can't believe they would just interrupt me like this.
That's so fucked up.
Alright, nice.
Don't let him hit you.
Why did you do that?
How could you let him hit you like that?
Just dodge, forehead.
Alright, nice.
all right
nice all right let's see if he actually cared about Jason he
would stop getting orphans to replace that's my hot take if
he actually cares about them why are they so easily
replaceable
all right let's see seesaw by outer gate where the fuck does
that mean what the fuck where is the other gate
here all cards all id cards are to be shown what is the
other gate here what does outer gate mean North, West.
Where's North?
There is a North.
Oh!
I figured it out!
Where's the seesaw?
Seesaw?
This is North, right?
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
I figured it out.
Nice.
Why is there Tweedle D and Tweedle D?
That's a real criminal?
That's just Alice in Wonderland.
Cousins with an uncannily resemblance to each other.
Deaver and Dumfrey Tweed.
Why the... I feel so bad for these kids.
That's when you know their parents did not love them.
Deaver and Dumfrey Tweed both shared criminal leanings in a
fixation on Lewis Carroll's Alice in Wonderland.
Teaming up, they've modeled themselves after Tweedle Dumb
and and tweedle d from that book planning often outrageous
and absurd schemes that trap the that is their real name wow
1940 yeah that seems like characters made it from 1943
oh yeah the mad hatter yeah i remember the mad hatter i
remember that from teen titans
uh do you know about the hidden room later on the game no
this is my first time playing this game one of my favorite
games.
Thank you.
Columbus.
Thank you again.
Wait, Jason used his guns?
The fuck?
Batman, you clearly have not taught your Robins well.
Wait, the Mad Hatter wasn't in Teen Titans?
Where was he in?
Was this in the Justice League Unlimited?
I swear he was in, like, one of the TV shows.
because I like unless he was unless he was in the comic book
series I actually owned some of the teen titan comics um
that was based off the that was based off the show I know
like he was from somewhere but I don't remember I remember
seeing the mad hatter in something
all right where's the bat cave I'm literally below it is it
like right here locate the cave cave at did i locate it oh
it's there okay i was gonna be like where oh my god i was
like i i located it question work i'm bat lost i am
directionally challenged batman one of my favorite batman
episodes from the anime series i don't know which anime
series this is like, oh, is it the Music Meister?
Oh, it's because Neil Patrick Harris.
That was when I had my how I met your mother craze.
Scan the thing beside me?
There's something beside me?
Oh, the Brave and the Bolt.
There's so many anime shows that I've, like, I have not kept
track of, like, what they're called.
Oh, there is!
The puzzle.
My family's blood ran through the heart of gotham we were
doctors politicians and teachers we have been the organ
cleaning the arterial filth from the city we have been its
servants giving all to protect it and still it has chosen to
hurt us so you're thinking of the super chat thing thank you
all villains in the game are from the comics except for
holly oh yeah i know harley quinn was invented just for the
animated show yeah i remember that all right apako
let's see i think like the best dc anime show was 100 of
justice league slash justice league unlimited i think
because like i think it aged quite well the writing for that
show aged incredibly well and it was not just for kids but
like adults could watch it too because it tackled like it
tackled like um moments in there that was meant for like
like even adults could understand like actual real moments
like they didn't like pussy out on shit
i will forever i will forever associate the voice like the
voices because like when they like redubbed martian
manhunter i could never i can never like deal with the new
voice actors for Martian Manhunter because the only voices I
associate with Martian Manhunter was from the Justice
League.
Nice, I did it.
God, millions.
Instead of paying taxes, he does this.
Young Justice was good.
Young Justice was good, but then every time you reboot a
show, it never goes well.
Because they have to compromise if they're rebooting a show.
And also it takes like a couple of years for that to happen.
So like the story that they wanted to tell was already like
watered down.
Except Samurai Jack.
Okay, remember the ending of Samurai Jack then say that
again.
Dr. Young was heading up a project.
It was big.
Lots of external funding.
Here are the last note she filed.
I can't make sense of it.
What does it mean?
Looks like she was experimenting on the Arkham patients.
This new chemical only barely resembles the original venom
compound.
There are a number of changes that appear to amplify the
strength of the drug.
Multiple references to a Titan formula.
Even a small amount could trigger a venom-like
transformation in the host, eliminating the need for the
storage tank Bane requires.
Hang on these notes aren't complete the formula is missing
that must be the secret dr. Young is hiding if Joker gets
his hands on this He will create an army of a thousand veins
My god is Joker crazy enough to do that?
What kind of yeah, it's gonna be like Barbara what the fuck
are you saying is Joker crazy enough to do bro?
What
You should never question about Joker's sanity.
Bruce Wade, thank you for the 50 gifted ships.
Holy fuck, thank you.
I appreciate it, Bruce Wade.
Instead of helping your city.
I mean, you know what?
Fuck it, that's all right.
You don't need to help your city.
Just keep gifting me my precious ships.
All right, nice.
I upgraded my fucking grapple hook.
I'm going after her.
She was heading to the mansion with cash I'm going up top
Why wouldn't cash have like a fucking Phone Just be like
cash don't do it She's fucking crazy Answer your phone cash
Alright how do I get out of here
Is he crazy enough to do it?
If he asks if somebody If he...
Bri bro she's shot...
Bri bro he literally made you paralyzed And you're asking is
he crazy enough to do this?
All right, so let Batclaw, LT, aim my Batclaw.
But what does the Batclaw do?
Oh, it just moves boxes.
That's stupid.
Whoops!
Sorry.
Oh my god, Batman, these platforms fucking suck.
all right let me okay i didn't realize i had to move all the
boxes oh my god this bat claw cost 100 000 what is its
purpose to remove boxes get it thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you um oh it opens vents too oh thank
fucking god it didn't all right good all right a hundred
thousand dollar backlog so fucking worth and why would you
hurt me reminding me the ending of samurai jack okay what i
hate was that people be like but doki they like they like
fixed it in the game yeah but the game is like mediocre it
wasn't even like the best fucking game ever it was like
super it was like just an average game and not everybody
fucking plays the samurai jack game too so it's like yeah so
people like there was a game so it's like like i understand
why but it's still the game might as well just put that
ending in the actual show
i'd be scared to criticize joker
I'm right, Jackie.
I feel like that's like one of Joker's many things.
Like, he doesn't kill.
He just does that.
Because, like, the amount of people he just puts people in
wheelchairs is, like, surprisingly a lot.
It's like his like go-to thing where he's like where he
instead of killing he just puts them in wheelchairs Which I
am always pretty fucked up Just like Batman
Yeah, he does kill but then it's like it's either kill or
wheelchair
Double tap for a weeder one's trying to open it this ain't
even the main door if Oh Wrong one.
Wrong one.
Oh, I'm fucking...
I chose the wrong one!
Whoa!
Why is it still not?
Oh, wait.
Sorry, I didn't know my left and right.
Sorry.
I pressed left T instead of right T.
I'm still learning my left and right right now.
now that makes much more sense actually no i was about to
send your guy to the hospital oh oh not a box okay nice no
come on how did you bet up okay nice i'm currently work but
real quick i want to say that enjoyed your streams for a
while you're so infectious when you're feeling joy you're
truly wonderful thank you plaster game thank you the super
chat thank you thank you all right i think uh i think you
look at the map real quick oh wait nice i can actually open
that now okay get over here all right nice oh and then yoink
mine now you hear that detective it's the sound of me
clapping at your success yeah
all right really you don't even have like an actual presence
in the game
If Killer Croc can find love, so can you, chat.
Whoa!
Then you go, they give us Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Also, Josh, they give us 10 gifted ships, thank you, thank
you.
One of Joker's oldest aliases.
So, Joker pays Dr. Young to create his army, and then all of
a sudden he stops.
Doesn't make any sense.
Open the door behind me?
behind me?
Here?
Is that killer crock?
Guys, I don't know.
The room where it's, like, glowing.
Oh, so sad.
Welcome to the tomato farm.
I was going to say dokey farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Also, I didn't manage to read your super chat illegal.
The Joker stalked and terrified dude for cutting him off in
traffic.
That's the next level and hint right there.
What you didn't know is that one journalist started
criticizing him, and then he...
like told him he's like you know what you're right i don't
have friends you're gonna become my best friend now and then
he like stalked this man for like several years and he
wouldn't let him have any friends after that because he was
like you don't need friends i am your best friend and then
he like killed his roommates and also like hurt his wife and
everything and and then because he was like you don't need
anybody else now I'm your best friend now forever and ever
but yeah anyway I don't know about opening this door
um oh no I'm gonna do it I shouldn't have done it
maybe I shouldn't have done that all right nice all right we
go this way oh more teeth teeth time yes teeth xp teeth xp
nice all right door open friendship goals no name thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you a puzzle has many
sides and i couldn't read the rest of the riddle oh there's
a wall i forgot about the wall right I noticed there's a
Riddler trophy I'm gonna be 15% done with the Riddler
trophies after this
hey all
right where's the guy I still hate that flashbang there's a
wall I swear I saw oh there it is nice another Riddler
trophy okay yeah tag the wall real quick gonna do a Banksy.
Boop.
It's a mysterious wall.
Noink.
Nice.
Where's your 3D model, Riddler?
That's fucking right.
Puzzle, but only some are visible.
See the Riddler put it...
Actually, wait, you're right.
Sounds like she had a change of heart.
She tried to blind her.
the payments joker doesn't like it when his partners try to
back out so he decided to get himself
exactly i just realized the ruler has been like placing
drywall around the place oh my god he's even a handyman well
wait i feel like is this oh yeah it's gonna say i was gonna
say this was not safe this is actually not safe at all he
had so much free time i've hacked into her email accounts
way and the second a message from joker
whoa joker says i'm coming for you
donkey no mystery why she's so scared again with the
wheelchairs Joker!
Payton, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
You're the first streamer I've ever gone my way to watch.
I'm so happy to be a dragon.
Love the content, but I'm glad you're here.
Thank you for the super chat, Payton.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying the content so far.
Also, sad.
Thank you for the 20 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
I told you guys.
It's on a killer wheelchair.
Like, Joker.
That's like his whole thing.
It's like, I'm not gonna kill you, but wheelchair.
All right, let's see this way.
The wheelchair kick is crazy.
Guys, I think the Joker has a problem.
What the fuck?
Oh, you found that one.
Sorry, it wasn't much of a challenge.
I was running out of time.
Okay, let's see.
I'll make sure there's nothing here.
Oh, Sonara, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
I'm here so I have to be held back.
Take this red because you're a tomato.
Thank you, thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you, thank you!
All right, this way.
There's a lot of wheelchairs in this series.
Oh, nice.
You're saying get over there?
Fuck.
Oh, wait.
Uh.
Wait, what the fuck?
How do I get over there?
Okay, let's get back here.
I'm glad I could, like, not have to worry about losing,
going back from the beginning.
Oh, not yet?
Use the back claw?
I feel like the back claw is not the right way.
Is it actually the back claw?
Can I pull this?
What's the point if I can't pull this?
What if I just pull this while down need line launcher oh i
don't have that yet okay we'll just go oh peace okay i want
to make sure there's no drywall again that the ridler put
out peace max thank you for the 10 gifted ships thank you
thank you and welcome to the tomato farm mossy pickles and
toaster welcome welcome
all right oh see no no drywall taped patient session 2
patient name Whalen Jones aka killer
crew poor choice of words no one's really normal are they
figured as much so how about this doc you let me go now and
I won't eat you you don't really eat people it's just
I don't know if you would like to play chicken with like a
guy that has a killer in his name
I feel like you know you're like you don't eat people mr
killer croc I don't know I feel like for the sake of your
safety if this guy's first name is fucking killer i don't
know i wouldn't fucking try and test that name out he kills
not eat yes but it's like similar thing like you still die
and she's like i you won't eat me oh yeah yeah instead of
eating he kills wow that is clearly the better alternative
like pacifist croc
all right let's see i feel oh yeah i can't i shouldn't go
over here crocs puts her in the wheelchair all right
return to a surface via oh i did it yay
ding dong don't worry about her
Snipers Looks like the black there's snipers
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, the other,
he is, sorry, I panicked Oh my god, I panicked so hard
Alright, give me a sec here Okay, there's no way If I just
Do that Can I just Okay, this is fucking useless Okay, where
do I go where is this okay arkham mansion if i keep running
if i keep running i'll be safe all right
okay which way is this all right i'll just keep running
there's no way they can catch me am i going the right okay
nope i will never go the right way apparently if i keep
running There's no way a bullet is fat.
You know I'm going to beat up the sniper.
Actually, fuck this.
I'm going to beat up the sniper.
Do I have stamina?
I forgot.
No, this is not a modern game anymore.
Get over here.
Get the fuck over here.
I forgot.
Stam- Oh, shit.
My punch is so strong.
The sheer velocity of my punch fucking hit him.
I forgot.
This game came out like 14 years ago.
So stamina wasn't invented back then.
Alright, how do I get there?
I think that's like the best part.
Like, oh shit, nice.
The good old days.
Where people were just so good at running.
Legacy of this island has been well and truly buried.
No?
Okay.
Oh, shit!
Whoops.
Alright.
Don't worry, I got it.
No, this.
That's fucking right.
The good old days.
Like, I understand they want things to be realistic, but,
like, also, like, I play video games not for the realism.
I play video games to escape reality.
want to have no fucking stamina I want no stamina it's 14
years ago games were actually made to be good I feel like
now games are just made to be like realistic but it's like I
don't want things to be realistic they give us a super chat
they can they can breeze eat should I save them
oh they're dead wait just to be sure oh yeah they're dead
wait they disappeared oh my god where the fuck did the
monsters go where the fuck did the people go saved good job
jokey you did it
what the fuck okay oh my get over here get over here get
over here Oh my god Okay
It's all about sending a message chat look I sent a message
to that one guy As long as that one guy knew what came knew
what went for him that's all that matters
whoo can I start hacking okay don't worry I got this all
right I'm just gonna fucking beat the shit out of them.
My only solution.
Fucking punch.
Oh shit, that's a wall.
Okay, it's fine.
Get over here.
Alright, nice.
What's over here?
Is this also a hack or can I just bat around this?
Can I?
Oh, I...
Boom.
No, I can't.
I have the hack.
Bro, fuck these snipers.
Status deceased.
Oh wait, recording.
I don't
think this is a persona.
Bro,
you just said you have a girlfriend!
Bro!
The Joker Riz I don't know I feel like I think like I don't
think you would want to have Joker be infatuated with you
Because like he would do Some crazy shit just to have your
attention I would have Joker Not be aware of my existence
Wee Or you know Just don't live in Gotham I feel like of all
the criminals like gotham city has all the worst ones like
not gonna lie oh yes your friend's gonna die here like um
every single criminal definitely like batman's handling the
worst ones
all right nice easy
just don't fucking live in gotham Like,
okay, so, like, I feel like, um, out of, like, all the,
like, most well-known, like, DC villains, majority of, like,
the most famous DC villains all live in fucking Gotham City.
Like, the Penguin, Bane, Joker, uh, Scarecrow, uh, Mr.
Freeze, um, all right, now think about the Flash villains.
Reverse Flash.
It was me.
I did it, Barry.
I did all of that.
All right.
Poison Ivy.
Harley Quinn.
Catwoman.
Grundy.
Two-face.
All right.
Superman.
His villains.
Reverse Superman.
Lex Luther.
Who's just like.
the evil billionaire batman but like even then it's like
it's not as bad as like the joker like superman lex loser um
um trucking bizarre yeah bizarreo and he was not even that
bad and then what was it i guess like general zod yeah and
then dark side but then like okay of like the Thanos of DC
but even then he just shows up like once every fucking five
years Joker is every day
anyway I'm saying is that I don't know maybe we should stop
living maybe Batman is outrageously terrible at his job if
like 80% of the most well-known villains live in Gotham City
Who it
is?
And me.
Yeah, big bad Batman.
Come on, tough guy.
Come and get us.
Oh, look at him.
Stuck out there.
Ain't you got a cat to rescue from a tree or something?
That's right.
Go on.
Get lost.
We're in control.
Joker will finish you off.
Bam.
Oh, shit.
All right.
There has to be, like, a place to grapple, right?
I don't even say Metro City is a...
a bad idea.
Wait, what?
I guess we have to, like, go up?
Anton, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Padoki forgot.
Captain Code.
A man who best splashed with a handheld refrigerator.
I feel like it has to be... Oh, there it is.
I see it.
Is that a vent?
Alright, no, I have to go back.
Use detective mode.
Wait, that's a vent, right?
Oh, shit.
Clayface is also Gotham City!
You're just making me more right!
Alright, nice.
I'm here now.
Nice.
Door open.
He just walked away.
He caved between his legs.
They tried to come through and take him on.
He wouldn't stand a chance.
Yeah, yeah, me too.
I'd rip his head off and give it to Joker for a paperweight.
Always sucking up to the boss.
What's that supposed to mean?
You heard me.
Okay, we have to kick the one with the gun.
Wee!
Oh my god!
It's like it came from a mile away.
There you go.
Nice.
Countered.
That's fucking right.
Hospital bills!
I guess I was like, but what about Cyborg Superman?
Who knew about Cyborg Superman?
Here.
More people know who the fuck the Riddler is.
The fucking Cyborg Superman.
Who the fuck is Cyborg Superman?
That was the first time I even heard about Cyborg Superman.
all right i had to tab out because my my chat died me
all right let's see okay dr young okay it has to be like
here let's see if there's anything i have to find out i
remember correctly the reason why that gothams criminals
always got out of was due to this warden, Hugo Strange, who
purposely let them loose to study Batman.
And this is also Batman's problem.
He funded, he fucking funded Arkham Asylum.
So like, isn't that his fault?
For like, hiring practices?
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That trophy was a test.
Well done.
Like, they could literally just have like an inspection to
make sure there's no corruption because like wouldn't Batman
be like that's weird why are the criminals keep escaping
almost every day surely the justice system isn't corrupt
because of that maybe it's just very unlucky that they keep
fucking escaping Arkham Asylum like at World's Greatest
Detective my fucking ass
Claire 20 gifted chests they could thank you damn that's
fucking crazy that people keep escaping
that's so crazy
oh shit look wheelchair oh no no he brought it to work i
like what i do here detective moaning right now is where
isn't this where oh there's a vent up here okay there's a
wind chair the choker is near all right nice okay all right
let's see well tagging it
there was like i remember there was like in the comic where
superman kills the joker and then batman was like i think
that's like one of my favorite like illustrate like one of
my favorite scenes because batman's just like because he's
like you can do that slowly filled with pain and suffering
the effects were felt everywhere my father fell first
infected by some foul disease my mother lived on but only in
a dream i returned to the family home to care for her where
she remained in her bed for as long as her body continue to
breathe her tears is this mr freeze at night no no because
it's a scarab because like it feels like you know like the
body thing but then like i'm not sure because it's a scarab
uh but yeah no if you guys didn't know that that like yeah
injustice like superman it's like where like basically it's
like evil the evil league or whatever and then it's so fun
there's like a comic scene of like the illustration of
superman killing joker and then i just love i love batman's
face I just love Batman's face in that because it's just so
fucking stupid it's just it actually
who is the main man in the main hall him this guy who else
would it be
I need to make sure there's like nothing here oh shit that's
a lot of people here whoops I was like, let me make sure
there's nobody here.
What the fuck?
What am I supposed to do?
Oh, wait.
Upgrade time.
All right.
Let's see.
What do we upgrade, guys?
Guys, what do we...
Oh, wait.
I could do that.
A and X.
Oh, my God.
I've just been pressing X this entire time.
Okay.
Powerful batter ramp.
All right.
Let's see.
Remote Bataran is really fun.
Okay, we'll try that.
Remote Bataran.
Okay, upgrade it.
Alright, how do I do this?
Alright.
Whoops.
How do I...
How do I fucking do that?
How do I control it?
I'm so confused.
Oh, shit.
How do I...
But how do I control it?
Fuck yeah, right?
Switch.
Oh, I have to select it?
Oh!
Okay.
My experiment.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
This is a lot harder.
Give me a sec.
This is actually...
I need to charge it!
Italian.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
World's greatest detective.
Also, Batman just one more trip to asylum it'll work this
time I swear okay okay here you go all right
okay that's pretty funny I'm just gonna chuck this I don't
I'm just gonna chuck this and then I want he'll eventually
die fuck this one guy in particular wait can I actually kill
him there's no way Okay, no way.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
There you go.
Alright, I'm just gonna fucking kill him.
Yay!
Oops.
There you go.
Okay, how do I throw you?
I need to throw you.
Please!
I need to throw you!
Let me throw you!
No!
one let me out okay nice all right get over here give me
that free fucking juicy xp i didn't eight combo oh my god
all right don't worry i'm getting it yes yes let me throw
yes all right now i'll never do that again that aim thank
you it's it's a great aim right there thank you the super
Nice.
I'll never have to throw again after that.
Use the bat bat.
Easy.
Oh yeah, that was easy.
Okay.
Let's grab the Riddler thing here.
I need that XP.
More wheelchairs.
Alright.
Give me...
Give me.
Okay, let's see, I need to make sure.
Alright, what-what's up this riddle?
Oh, hey, teeth.
Teeth.
Alright, what's the answer to this riddle, guys?
Riddle me this.
There's so many, like, areas to...
Alright, open.
What is this?
Oh, another tape.
As yet, the patient has been on the-
whoa oh he's doing his own interview oh what a plot twist oh
that was the scarecrow okay it's still underneath the statue
what does that even mean oh my god look at all these bodies
also like it's not great that they passed out too that just
means like like it's like even okay no not that no not that
no not him that's a gargoyle
i'll never figure out i'll never figure it out apparently
see is there anything i'm missing just need to make sure i'm
not missing anything oh shit more tvs
The West Wing.
Nope, not that.
Wait, there's a scare up there.
It didn't see unknown.
Nope, not that.
It's in the side hall.
What the fuck is a side hall?
What the fuck is the side hall?
This hall wing?
Did you see it?
I'm just gonna grab these teeth.
It's a hall on the side.
Thanks, guys.
Oh my god, this fucking tooth.
Alright, nice.
Can I just open this door?
That's it?
It's just for the teeth?
Let's see.
Where do I go from here?
I can't get through from here.
Because all the areas locked.
Huh.
Where the fuck do I go?
Straight ahead to the left?
Wait, okay, what's the map?
Oh, there's a door!
Wait, there's a door right here.
I can open doors.
Oh, there it is!
The side hall!
Arrest recognition award for your outstanding contribution.
Well, to be fair, if they keep getting out, you can always
keep arresting.
Like, if you think about it.
Oh my god we found it.
It was the hall on the side.
What does a bird need in the rain?
Okay.
Cover?
Let me make sure that... Alright there is one person here.
An umbrella.
I mean everybody needs an umbrella.
Why is it just a bird?
Boop.
Destroyed five Joker teeth.
I'm pretty sure I destroyed more.
Aim and throw well-being scene when you're in the corner
cover.
Okay, watch this.
Watch this.
Give me a sec.
Oh, it's the penguin!
Riddle me this I totally knew that
No No, I'm dying Don't die
Don't die What no Okay, get him, get him out of here We're I
got the gun, I got the gun It's okay, I got the gun gun,
guys.
It's okay.
He's not going to pick up the gun.
He's not smart enough for that.
He's not smart enough.
It was so close.
What do you mean?
I almost got it.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
If Doki got hit with the Scarecrow's nightmare gas, she had
hallucinate a giant map.
Thank you for the super chat.
chat thank you thank you how is i supposed to know okay i
paint that
nice what's in here oh it's just this it's another chronicle
oh my journey lasted little over a month visiting academics
in both metropolis and keystone i was exposed to a wealth of
new ideas I began my day, returning home and good spirits.
Eager to see my wife and family.
I ended it kneeling in their blood.
Yeah, I was going to say, the most, whenever they're like,
I'm eager to see my family, they're never alive.
Poor guy.
He lost his family.
Oh, hey, what's this?
Hoop.
All right, pull that down.
Pull that down.
It's in one of the cases?
Where the fuck is the umbrella?
Is it...
No?
Where is the umbrella?
Okay, that's not an umbrella.
Where the fuck is the umbrella?
Oh, there it is!
Shit, that's a lot of umbrellas.
Nice.
Riddlesong.
The penguin.
One of Batman's oldest four.
is an eccentric criminal mastermind known as much for his
love of ornithology and trick umbrellas as for shady
business dealings.
Gothen's popular iceberg lounge serves as cobble pot's front
for a number of illegal financial activities that fund much
of the city's underworld.
Despite his short stature, Penguin is a wildly foe whose
umbrellas conceal a variety of deadly weapons and gadgets.
All as well, Chesterfield cobble pot.
I like how this one's not a professional Like a restaurant
owner.
No big deal.
He's just...
Okay, that is...
There's no way he's 5 foot 2.
I'm 5 foot 2.
There's no fucking...
He's lying about his height.
There's no way.
Because if Batman is 6 feet...
You think about it.
Okay, Bruce Wayne.
Where is Bruce Wayne?
Where the fuck is Bruce Wayne?
There's no fucking way Bruce Wayne is 6 foot 2 Okay, if you
imagine 5 foot 2 Like, it's not like Okay Oh, it counts the
top hat?
Okay That makes more sense now Because I was like, there's
no fucking way This guy is 5 foot 2 When, like, every time
you put him next to the Penguin, like, if you put him next
to the Batman, he's like, he reaches This is like Batman's
crouch or something.
And I'm like, there's no fucking way.
A 5'2 prince will feel like that short.
You guys are like, Doki, that's some sick copium right now.
I refuse to believe that that's a 5'2".
There's no fucking way.
I refuse to believe it.
That's just too sad.
Oh, hey, guys.
Let me go back outside.
You're toky-go.
Why is it up here?
I'm like trying to think, okay, I'm just going to beat
people up here.
Wait, I'm just going to make sure there's no...
Um...
Oh, I have to open the door.
I want to make sure there's no guns.
No guns?
No guns.
Okay.
Well, I don't really care.
I'm just gonna beat them up.
Yeah!
Oh shit.
I really don't care.
Okay.
Oh shit, there's so many people!
It's okay.
I'm good.
Nice, y'all, stun.
No, counter!
Okay, stun.
Nice.
If all else fails, just keep pressing X and sometimes Y.
Six and black, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you.
Oh no, I made him back up.
Who needs stealth when I can just stealth them with my
fists?
There's hostages here?
Oh shit.
That's clearly not caring about that.
The pirate, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I didn't know.
Doki comes in penguin size.
The only way I could have made that one easier to find is if
I strapped it to the hood of that ludicrously ostentatious
vehicle of yours.
All right, let's make sure that there's no other criminals
around.
that's what i'm saying that's why i'm like there's no way
there's no way paying on his five foot two he's lying about
his fucking height i'm basically correct
okay oh i kid i was like i'm gonna cut the chandelier why
don't they cut the chandelier
Two minutes, and the giggle gas goes boom.
They're gonna be cheering up those miserable doctors.
Oh, shit, two minutes.
Wait, does it count?
Let's try to figure out how to do the chandelier.
Oh, God.
Don't do well under pressure, Joker.
Never do well under pressure.
Oh, God.
Okay, I need to be in detective mode.
I can think better.
I don't even know if it's time yet.
What do I do?
Cutting.
Cut.
You gotta say.
I'm getting bored already.
Maybe I should just test them out.
Boo.
What do I do?
Um, what do I do?
Oh, there it is.
Open.
Do not open before.
Okay.
Thank you, Banner.
man are they all gone yes you're safe what happened it all
happened so fast some patients broke in began tearing up the
place like they were looking for something bill here fought
back but there were too many they took dr young she rushed
in here and they followed i'm sorry when i came to we were
all tied up doc young was gone doctor you're a guard back
here thank you thank you thank you thanks for the fun stream
and funny moments keep your head up donkey thank you think
of the super chat thank you thank you i'm glad you've been
enjoying the stream oh my god all right guys i need help how
do i solve riddle me this how do i solve this it was like
something out of thin air riddle me this what the fuck does
that mean
do not open before april first love joker no clue there's a
book there's so many books.
Whoa!
Maybe this?
Open door?
No, that's where I came from.
This Finnish puzzle, literally the library.
Oh, wait!
There's no puzzle here.
Look at the map.
Oops.
This?
Oh, there's a sitting...
Wait, did I go in there hidden room yet?
Can't tell.
There's a book in the library.
There is?
I think it has to be above.
Oh, hey, there's another...
Wait, I didn't see this.
What's this?
Oh, in the previous room.
It's okay, I needed this anyway.
I need the Riddler Trophy.
Alright, down I go.
Alright.
Goodbye.
Okay, where is the door?
I'm so fucking lost.
There's two riddles in here?
Joker, riddler.
Why did mom let you have two riddles?
There is?
There's no book here.
Greetings for losers.
what the fuck is the book I'm gonna go up here just in case
look to my left guys don't you guys remember that like I
don't know my left and my right there is a question mark
fuck okay okay this is a little embarrassing Oh, there it
is!
Okay, all right, let's see.
I must be able to...
All right, through...
Oh, fuck, not the floor.
Wait, it doesn't matter?
What are you in pre-perspective?
Like this?
What do you mean?
grapple on the vent and do the perspective all right we got
this like that how's that not lying what the fuck go higher
I'm already as high as I can be okay maybe god damn it sorry
I'm too stupid for this are you fucking You fucking see
there's a dot next to my feet.
There's a dot next to my
I figured it out It's like I'm standing it this entire time
Oh my god I didn't realize I was standing on the fucking dot
I was like what do you mean?
There's a dot next to my feet Yes, XP time.
Thanks, Joker, for setting me more experience points.
Boom.
Concussion time.
World's greatest detective, by the way.
That's me.
That's me, guys.
Do you guys know I am the world's greatest detective?
I'm just...
Where do I go now?
Because, like, this door is still locked.
Biggest brain moment.
Go back to the library?
Where's the library?
Did I go back?
Did I went the wrong way?
Please don't tell me they're back already.
The self-corridor.
There's another door?
Why did I miss the other door?
Oh wait, because I'm blind.
That's how.
Oh, there is another door right here.
No!
Stop tagging your signature!
There you go.
God damn it.
I'm just gonna make sure.
I'm just gonna make sure I don't miss anything.
Wait, no, I was here.
Batman was here.
Where's the map?
Where did I not go?
Chat lied.
God damn it, chat!
Where do I go?
Oh my god.
God fucking...
Okay, I guess...
I guess I...
I leave?
I guess...
We're at the top of the tower!
Okay.
Don't believe our lies.
Back to the main hall.
God fucking damn, I knew it.
I knew you guys were fucking with me.
I knew it.
Go to the north corridor.
The main hall.
Where's north?
North is up.
Is this north?
Don't believe their troops either, but there's a door.
Get over here.
That's fucking right.
Bam!
Nice.
What?
Wait, what?
What's that collar do?
Why is it making that noise?
It's the suicide collar, but it sounds weird.
what they've got some other name but well we just use them
to monitor patients heartbeats if it drops too low the alarm
goes off and a crash team rushes in we are killed if you
trigger one how do you like them apples bats standing around
in the let's see ah the west wing oh this is definitely not
north now if they weren't busy knocking a little sense into
cash i'll tell you what i won't spoil the surprise and let
them know you're coming Wait, did I kill?
Did I kill?
Oh, hey, upgrade.
Alright.
Let's upgrade time, guys.
What are we getting?
Alright.
I am never...
Guys, all I know is that...
Is that...
It was a mistake to listen to you guys when you said remote
battery.
Oh, wait.
No upgrades.
Never mind.
I'm saying...
was that the remote batter ad was not helpful.
It's not because I can't aim.
Alright, I'm just going to let you guys know.
It's not because it was me.
It's not a me issue, okay?
It is not a me issue.
I just want you guys to know that.
It is not a skill issue.
You know what?
Is this like a structural weak?
Oh, wait, look.
Security.
Okay, I can't get there yet.
And I can't do that yet, either.
I guess I'll open the door.
Oh, that's a lot of...
That's a lot of guns.
Nice.
Boop.
Hello.
Oh, I guess like, it can be used to uh come on come on no it
was so close what if i just do this and then i oh oh okay
that's awkward that is so awkward that is so awkward come on
come over here wait up i'll watch your back come over here
come on Okay, but what if...
Oh my god, there's way too many people here.
Okay, wait, wait, this is what we do.
There's no way I... Okay.
Okay.
There's no way I could fuck this up, guys.
Bam!
I told you!
I told you there was no way I could fuck this up.
I wonder if he can pick up his gun again.
I want to know if he can pick up his gun.
Can you pick up his gun?
Okay, let's just go glad kick him.
Boom.
Okay.
Making sure you keep quiet.
Nice.
Oh, shit, he does.
There's no way he does.
There's no way.
Okay.
Wait.
Maybe it is good.
realize I could do get triple kill?
I didn't realize it was bullying.
If I knew it was bullying.
Alright, whoever whoever fucking suggested the remote
control battering, you were right.
You were right.
boy trip up where did dr young go i told her to run these
guys came in looking for i told her to go to her office and
hide does she keep her records there i guess she was pretty
desperate to get in there her office is over there how long
ago was this i need to find her notes before joker gets his
hands on them 20 minutes maybe i really hate the bat suit
like that he's wearing his ears are too long like i just
want to i want to grab a pair of scissors and just cut it
okay investigate dr young's location thanks for the help
back there i just don't like how short long it is i just
want to grab a pair of scissors and just go snip snip all
right this way It would be better if it was just Mr. Matt.
Go Matt or was he just dizzy?
That's fucking right, Joker.
Yeah, but your crew is just like, criminals.
Like, like the jockeys.
They're not scientists.
Never a joke.
Because I have too much money to stop now.
This is literally just my hobby.
Oh hey, teeth.
Nice.
I only destroyed 10?
I feel like I destroyed so many.
Alright, what?
That's it?
Where did I go?
Justin, welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Oh hey.
what I feel like this is yeah I was gonna say oh it's him
alright oh he's a crazy guy founded the Elizabeth Arkham
Asylum for the criminally insane naming it after his oh my
god why would you name that after your mom oh that's why who
he euthanized as treatment for dementia building it on the
old grounds his family historic mansion on the outskirts of
Gotham, personally treated its first patient, Martin Mad Dog
Hawkins, but killed the wife and daughter.
After administering fatal electro-shock treatment to
Hawkins, he lost all grip on insanity and was admitted into
his own institution.
Oh shit, how tall is he?
The most important information I need to know.
tall was he.
Alright, nice.
Is it?
This is where I...
Oh, wait, no.
This is different.
God, there's so many vents and everything.
Nice.
Riddle me this.
Go!
Welcome to the Tameha farm!
Welcome, welcome!
Alright, down I go.
Two unarmed.
You can be the one Oh, there he is.
I was like, what the fuck?
Yeah.
Wham!
Boop!
Alright.
Oh, no.
Let me make sure he doesn't pick up his gun again.
That's fucking right.
Dodge this!
My fucking fist!
I have too much money!
Ow.
The little fucking...
The little fucking slap.
Nice.
It's that easy.
We're trying to get into that office.
It looks like they couldn't get through the main door.
Got to find a different way in.
Just punch it.
Oh my god.
Wait.
Okay.
But why can't I just blow it up with my fucking batter
explosion?
Like, there's no way it only works on drywall.
That's so fucking stupid.
Why can't I just blow it up?
Because it's not...
That's wrong.
Fucking weak.
What's the point of having explosives if they're weak as
fuck?
I have so much money!
It's anti- it is anti-tri-walk explosion.
Scan the body.
Really?
Yeah, those bodies don't matter.
Oh, these bodies?
That's a cold day in hell when this...
Oh, wait, is that Raul Ghul?
That's him?
Lil is known of the early years of the...
That's your future father-in-law.
Whose name means the demon's head.
But it's known that he has lived for many centuries due to
Lazarus' pits.
Mystical and alchemical bruise that restore his youth.
A brilliant master of strategy and organization.
Raul Ghul's goal is to save the earth from ecological
devastation.
by destroying most of his population.
He recognized Batman as both a worthy foe and a possible
ally.
Except that Batman cannot escape his dystopian worldview.
Batman also shares his love-hate relationship with Raz's
daughter.
The beautiful Talia.
You know, like, I would never understand why Batman is like
ageless, but like his robins grow up.
I find that like really weird.
like I understand they don't want him to like age because
then like because he's Batman so they can use him forever
but like but like all his like adopted sons and daughters
like age with him and then like at one point Dick Grayson is
now like sort of the same age as Batman if you think about
it because like if he's like 20 is Dick Grayson is like 20
and 30 then how old is like 60 or something but he's not
like if you think about it that's why i don't understand i
don't understand what like just don't just don't age but i
guess they're like we need more robins we need more robins
we can't keep having dick as a robin because i don't we hate
calling him dick
he's been in the pit like it's understandable like
superman's age this because he's a fucking alien already
got to the safe the only question now is who opened it the
doctor sign of forced entry whoever opened it knew the
combination the surfer richard yeah but he's still everyone
still calls him fucking dick before joker she's taken them
to hide somewhere i need to follow her and find out where
she put them oh scan the mask oh the black mask i know this
give me the mask okay it won't let me scan
oh what what the fuck
what the fuck
scan huh what do i do i have to press oh finish this mission
first i don't know where he wants me to look at the cameras
oh here oh the safety deposit okay whoops whoops scanning it
has to be her oracle
i'm on dr young's trail i've had to calibrate the scanner to
only show recent prints if i follow these i will find her or
the notes I hope it works.
Just so you know, the GCPD found one of Joker's bombs
downtown.
It was...
As I thought, it's just a twisted diversion.
The real action's on Arkham.
Oh, shit.
Okay, now I can scan.
No.
Now I can scan.
Nice.
Yay!
Whoops.
Following the suspicious death of this multi-million
parents.
Oh, my God.
How many...
Okay, there's a lot of them.
millionaires but how many millionaires live in fucking
gotham like
inherited their fortune and then went on to bankrupt their
company saved by a buyout by bruce wayne he came to resent
and hate wayne oh my god everyone hates him because he just
spends money i guess fixated on the concept of mask he
carved one from his family's black coffin and sought revenge
his ensuing battle with the dark night caused him as the uh
caused his mask to be burnt into skin remaking him as the
black mask he is now a feared gang leader and one of the
most powerful mod bosses in Gotham a burning hatred of
Batman bro like everybody hates him get in line
get in fucking line everyone hates him you're not special I
forgot what upgrade you guys wanted.
What was the upgrade you wanted?
Wait, his height!
Wait!
Doki, you have to look at his height!
Okay, what do we upgrade for?
Take down?
Instant take down?
Is this it?
Special combo take down.
It's not available yet.
Unless it's in another one.
Armor upgrade.
Nope.
Better at power.
Not available.
Where the fuck is the Instant takedown.
Auto proximity.
It is?
Locked in your...
Oh, is this...
Oh, oh!
Okay, I didn't see that.
Okay, I didn't...
Whoops.
B-N-Y.
Alright, nice.
Okay, now I can open doors.
No.
Okay, apparently not.
I have to go through.
Apparently not, guys.
Where did I come from?
Oh, it's just like, where am I?
All right, here we go.
All right, don't worry, I want to see your faces when I beat
the shit out of you.
Spam.
That's all right.
I love pressing spamming X.
It's my favorite part.
That's fucking right.
can beat me up.
You're just goons.
You're not special.
You don't even have names.
Get out of here.
His height will never know.
We'll never know his height.
It's gonna be a mystery forever.
Oh, I forgot this one, T.
Where's the record's office?
It's this way?
The tape?
Go back!
I missed the tape?
There was a tape?
I was too busy beating people up.
Oh, there it is.
Patient interview six.
My sessions have been in.
What do you mean, Stephen?
How are you today?
Dr. Murphy is still in therapy.
I wanted to understand him.
His personal demons, his fears...
I feel like Bruce should spend more money on the mental
health situation here.
Is there like a multiverse where Bruce Wayne actually spends
his money on fixing the mental health issues in Gotham
rather than beating up mentally ill people?
How do you think about it?
Like,
I just realized, would it be better to fund research on,
like, like, I mean, I feel like you didn't try that hard.
I feel like, I feel like beating up, beating up people is,
like, sort of, like, the last resort.
I feel like I don't know it doesn't feel like he tried all
that hard to fix the issue
chill thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you
raise more money for mental health in 24 hours and Bruce
Wayne did in his whole career thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you Prince, thank you for the magenta soup,
but thank you, thank you.
Hey, Toge, glad to see you're enjoying this game.
I used to play it when I was a kid.
Can't believe how old it looks now compared to when it came
out.
Thanks for the fun stream.
I recently lost my Oshi, and these are keeping me alive.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you.
I'm glad you've been enjoying it.
Thank you.
I thought you guys said go to the library.
Is this not the library?
Is this not the fucking library?
Guys, I think I got baited.
I think I got baited.
Find a book.
Oh, is it book time?
This is it?
This is not the library, but there's books.
There's more than one library?
Guys, there's more than one library why the fuck did we fund
all these libraries for oh there it is okay fingerprints
fingerprints okay i found the fingerprints okay
and then the trail disappears okay all right Where the fuck
are the prince?
I followed it.
I followed all the fingerprints.
The two fingerprints.
I mean, Harleen Quinzel was a psychiatrist.
And look where she ended up.
The chunky.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Yes.
But then they got to hire people outside of Gotham City.
Why are we still hiring doctors in Gotham City?
They're clearly not reliable.
Okay, it's a bottom floor.
Oh, there it is.
I didn't realize it was, like, super close.
Oracle, I found Dr. Young's formula.
Great.
So does that mean you've stopped Joker?
You never stopped Joker.
What do you mean?
It's never this simple with him.
Yeah, I was gonna say.
what rescued dr young from zass in the warden's office wait
is that gas oh not good okay we gotta go back oh that's not
good well let me leave those two back there
Sucks to be those...
Oh no, I missed the scarecrow gas.
It's the scarecrow gas.
God damn it.
I still left those two people there, so...
Sucks to be those two.
Can't believe you insisted on sitting through that movie
again, Bruce.
Oh no, it's the crime alley.
I'm sorry, Daddy.
He loved it, so Albert will wait.
Keep up, Bruce.
All right, time to relive trauma.
This is where you're... Oh, shit.
What?
Wait, it's actually called Crime Alley?
I thought that was a joke in Teen Titans!
And like...
Wait!
Okay.
The Wave family is actually stupid as fuck.
Like, if you are like...
multi-billionaires you would not go down crime alley like
that's just like that's actually just fucking stupid like i
thought that was a joke i didn't realize it was actually
called crime alley it's starting to rain roose is tired
can't we just wait for him here come on keep up we're nearly
there all right here we go down in crime alley here we go
self-fulfilling prophecy I'll shoot.
I'll give you whatever you want.
We
died in Crime Alley.
It's true that's Crime Alley.
Um, Doki, it's Latin.
Why?
Crime Alley was supposed to be safe!
Oh, there's the my bat.
My bat's safe.
Oh, I can move?
Come on, kid.
This way.
Take a seat in my office.
Is he okay?
He'll be fine.
Kid like that with all that money.
He'll be just fine.
Shut up.
No.
He's eight years old and all alone.
I mean, money cannot fix trauma.
Bro, that's fucked up.
Wait, what is...
I mean, there's no blood.
I just need to ask...
you some questions can i get you anything i'm a tiny little
boy i know you don't feel like answering me but it's the
only way to catch you did this
i don't know it's this city there's something wrong with it
and listen son call me jim whoa i look back at my oh my
parents are okay all right all right so that was james james
gordon oh no back to the scarecrow we go all right here we
go here we go again there is these
whoa he's back i thought beat the shitter of you okay okay i
can hide here Nice.
I can keep running.
I can- No!
Fuck!
Okay.
You failed.
Now suffer.
Alright, use the black- Oh!
The back cloud to create new cover.
Okay, I didn't realize you could do that.
Fuck!
Sorry, I got a little impatient.
I got- I got a little impatient.
I thought I could run fast!
Alright.
All right, here we go.
Okay.
All right, now I know...
Whoa.
Here we go.
What did I...
Okay, okay, I was gonna say.
I was worried that, like...
Uh...
I was worried that, like, me pulling it down will also
trigger him.
I like all these different mechanics, though.
Because it's not...
It's not just one thing.
All right, run, run, run, run, run.
run he they were murdered by Joe chill that's just sad well
okay nothing it was nothing oh shit all right I can beat up
the skeletons sorry okay it's a little funny to see like to
see a skeleton try to sucker punch me it's a little It's a
little quirky there.
Yeah, you got a little bit no-chill.
Also, like, they're billionaires.
Why are they watching a movie with the public?
I bet you they have their own home theater.
Wouldn't they have their own home theater?
Okay.
I want to know how this is going to go back and forth.
Yoki, what if they just want to live a normal human, a
normal life?
All right, you don't understand.
They wanted to know what it was like out there, like the
common folk.
All right, let's see.
It wasn't a theater, it was like a movie.
retcon that again.
Oh, God.
No!
I jumped the wrong way!
It was the opera?
I thought it was movie theater.
And at the end of fear, oblivion.
Unless it got retconned, I went the wrong way.
I swear to god at one point it was a movie yeah it was the
movie okay they reconned it so many times that it stopped
making sense like this is why this is also why the comic
industry is like dying because they keep they recon like oh
my god please they recon so many times that like that like
it's just hard to like keep up with thing and they rebooted
so many fucking times like it's just it's just a headache
because you guys are like no it's the opera and I was like
it was the opera I hope it was the movies okay well I guess
I'm not gonna get off the pillar I can't get off of it I
can't get it all
right move all the other side okay nice okay they got us
like a cat please let me go all right give me the skellies
give me the skellies get over here get the fuck over here I
just love how they have the they even have crowbars you
think that's gonna kill me you don't muscle on those bones
all right All right, nice.
I've got a bone to pick with you.
Hello, Mr. Bones.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right, climb.
Oh, RB.
Okay.
Oh, there's no...
I don't think there's gonna...
Okay, yeah, there's here.
You're gonna stop looking?
Where is he looking at?
I can't tell where's he looking at it was worth it it was
worth it thank you for it was worth it I guess super it was
worth it it was worth it oh I made it I made it there you go
it was totally It's really worth it.
I could get there.
I could get there before he looks at me!
Nice.
The scarecrow hired them.
I'm here!
No?
Zaz has Dr. Young trapped in the warden's office.
I've got to get out of here.
How do I get out of here?
Am I stuck here?
Do I...
Wait.
Okay.
I didn't think I could break that rope because it's a pretty
thick rope.
Yay!
Who needs to tell time?
I'll just fix it with money later.
Yay!
Property damage does not matter for me.
Alright.
Oh hey, the bridge is...
or like not the bridge the gates oh my god wait yeah proper
damage does not fucking matter because like i'm so fucking
rich i if i break property i can just fix it with money a
game of cat and mouse can be painful okay
let's see that's my superpower i'm just gonna fucking beat
him up oh shit you know what i can't I can take him.
Alright.
That's fucking right.
Boom!
That's...
Oh, shit!
Okay.
What?
Alright.
Come on.
There we go.
Wait, how do I kill him, then?
How do I kill him?
Do I just...
Oh.
Okay.
that was easy nice sorry how do I make sure he just doesn't
get up but like still be alive
how is that break this oh I can that reminds me that's why
we have so many TVs.
What?
No!
Joker, that's fucked up!
Wait, where do I go?
Oh no.
Maybe...
Is there...
Will there be this?
Oh.
Wait a minute.
Oh no, that's just the bathroom.
Sir, I would like to use the bathroom real quick.
Boop.
Not the ears, but what about all the wheelchairs?
Joker, that is a waste of a perfectly good wheelchair.
Cerberus, welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Is that everything?
I thought there would be like an actual...
I felt like there would be like an actual like...
trophy here.
Seros, thank you for the 10 gifted ships.
Thank you.
What the fuck?
What's the point of going in here?
There's no trophy?
I feel scammed.
I can't believe there was no trophy.
Hello?
What the fuck is this guy?
Is that Zaz?
No way, I'm coming over.
Oh, shig.
Now that was unexpected.
I'm sorry, I want the trophy was right there!
But the trophy!
No, you don't understand!
The trophy was right there!
Listen to me carefully.
I'm coming over.
Come any closer.
No!
I crouched at everything!
I don't understand.
I even crouched.
Listen to me carefully.
I guess I'll help.
I'm any closer.
And I'll paint the room crimson with her blood.
Weeer.
I know you're still out there.
I'm sorry.
The trophy was so disdain.
Give me my trophy.
He's not going anywhere.
You can stop now.
Sorry.
I'm so sorry.
I saw Bane.
I know.
I-Joker threatened me.
I wanted to stop the experiment.
I tried to give him his money back.
You don't just give back money from- Yeah, you don't just
give back money from- He doesn't give a fuck about money!
You think he cares about money?
So now he has venom and your formula.
God, I hate his ears.
I want to, like, just cut his ears off.
Hidden in the gardens.
It's locked off, but the security key comes.
for the entire island are in the warden's safe what else is
joker it's just in the warden's safe everything says makes
sense i think he's insane oh my god oh shit yeah i thought
it was just obviously a bomb i feel like he'd see the
joker's face first like the the the spray paint
Oh!
He needs to watch.
Oh shit, there he is.
Wait, what about the doctor?
All right, nice.
All right, as long as the fucking guy with the shocker
doesn't get near me, it's fine.
Let me get this guy out real quick.
Okay, get up.
here oh no get out of here let me kill this guy first god
damn it get out leave me alone okay there you go let me just
run around him reggie thank you for the five give the shows
thank you thank you mecca he's not going anywhere he's
already got out twice tonight thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you thank you have you figured out a way
past the security gate oh she's dead she told a production
plant hidden somewhere in the gardens the wane tech security
protocols seem to be hack proof we just did a good job
influencer
and destroyed by joker in the safe explosion harley quinn
has the warden and he's the only chance we have to get past
these gates okay good luck oh she's dead i was like where is
she oh you mean the body part that's surrounded by blood
Where could she be?
Sorry, I didn't notice that was actually here.
Nice.
Oh, shit, what's this?
Are there secrets, map?
Nice.
So, you have given in and taken my map.
I hope it proves useful.
Are there there's a secret room?
She was...
not bomb proof there's no fucking way okay there is a really
trophy here scan surface in room which surface which surface
oh hey there's the the ventriloquist isn't the warden too
old for a puppet show wait that's scar yeah the the scar
face and the ventriloquist Gothen's Blackgate penitentiary
once had a gallows tree from which 313 criminals with death
sentences were hanged.
The wood from the pup, the tree, was widowed by an inmate
into the puppet's scarface.
And that inmate was once his height and was murdered by
Arnold Wesker, a man who would soon fall under Scarface
influence.
While most believe that Scarface is simply a tool through
which Wesker, as the criminal mastermind, the ventriloquist,
acts out a dark side to his personality, Wesley himself
believes that Scarface is possessed by the souls who died
beneath the gallows tree and the puppet actually motivates
him to commit the duo's many crimes I hear like Scarface is
now like under like a woman is now the new ventriloquist
because the original ventriloquist fucking died So where is
the secret you guys said there's a secret
It's in the walls.
It's in the walls, don't you?
That wall.
Thank you, guys.
I really appreciate the guidance of the walls.
This wall?
I'm up against the wall.
Punch every wall.
Okay, now I actually don't know if you're fucking with me.
I cannot...
tell if you're fucking up left entrance.
Oh, secret has to use a gel.
A gel.
Okay, so but then I don't see it, though.
Okay.
That was if I gel everything.
If I gel everything, eventually.
Three gels.
Three Here we go.
It was not that wall.
Right next to this one?
All will be jail.
Eventually...
Oh, and the floor, I guess.
And the floor.
Oh, three in the same place?
Look up.
Why the fuck would I look up?
Okay.
It's technically the same place.
Whoa!
I did it.
Oh, Floor.
What is this?
What?
What is that?
Oh, is this Scarface?
Like...
Secret tunnel.
Look at the blueprint.
This one?
This blueprint?
What blueprint do I...
Was this Arkham City?
Oh, is this like...
Oh!
Oh, is this like a...
Oh, zoom in?
Yeah, is this... I was going to say, is this like a plan
for...
No?
Not letting me zoom.
This is a plan for the sequel, right?
Oh, that's cool.
It was like a sequel bait.
Well, I already know Arkham City was next.
It just makes me think that...
Because, like, back then, I feel like 10 years ago...
Or 14 years ago.
People don't really like, what was it, data mine stuff back
then?
I mean, people did, I feel like.
Actually, people did.
But, like, it wasn't as, like, intense as it was in the, it
was, as it is now, I feel like.
Wait, there must be, like, a cat and mouse here somewhere.
If it, if it's, like, cat and mouse.
Yeah, it wasn't as common.
So I feel like someone must have been, like, just fucking
plant, just spraying every fucking wall.
All right, riddle me this.
Scan the display.
This one.
Which display?
Bathroom mirror.
Scan yourself.
There's a mirror?
There is no mirror here.
Yeah, I was gonna say it.
I feel like it has to be a display case.
Is that it?
Oh, there it is.
Catwoman.
Riddles.
A Batman.
An Orthon who learned to survive on Gotham City Streets.
Selina Kyle took to thievery to survive, but determined to
do in style.
She learned martial arts and trained extensively to perfect
her skills at cat burglary.
Her criminal activities are often tampered with by reluctant
altruism, making her inconstant...
Oh, he's like an anti-hero.
Is that the right word?
uh constant constant villain and occasional hero she
regularly eludes captured by the dark night and retains a
complicated aversional relationship with batman that
frequently turns flirtatious and occasionally legitimately
romantic nice oh teeth that's right batman you got some
all right does that save my game i think it does all right
We are gonna call it here, guys.
Oh, hey, gosh, I'm really tired.
I'm gonna call it here.
I had a long day.
Oh, that was really fun, though.
That was really, really fun.
I've been enjoying Batman Arkham Asylum.
I'm so happy to actually be able to play this game now
because it's honestly been a game I've been wanting to play
for the longest time.
And it's honestly been, it's been really fun.
I have to say, it's actually been very, very fun so far.
And as someone that is, like, really into, like, DC stuff,
it's, like, nice to, like, and then, like, you guys, too.
You guys, like, know everything I'm talking about.
It's just nice to, like, actually, like, talk about, like,
the DC lore and, like, the DC comics and the DC shows and
stuff.
like that just talking about like superheroes and stuff so
it's like nice to know you guys understand my references and
even if you like didn't it's because you guys get to learn
with with me too um but yeah thank you everybody i noticed i
wanted to do a super chat reading after this but i did read
some super chats as we went along but i'm very very tired
right now so i'm gonna call it here and rest up uh but thank
you everybody i really enjoyed streaming today stay
hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get that
blood flowing.
And if you say, what for me?
Head to bed because you deserve it.
Hell Divers 2 tomorrow.
And I hope that the servers won't be too bad tomorrow.
Guys, please, I request you guys to not go, to not play Hell
Divers 2 so I can play on the server.
Guys, I would like to be able to play Hell Divers 2
tomorrow.
Let me have, let me get into the survey.
No, you have to fight.
Guys, if you want to watch me play Hell Divers, too, you
guys need to pause real quick and not play that day.
You can watch me play.
Live vicariously through me.
Anyway, I'll see you guys later, everybody.